and let's go next to our caller from the
eight-six to area code who's calling
today from eight-six - yes that's you
yes and we're not on speakerphone right
no all the connections so bad so it just
sounds a little echoey what's your name
hi I'm sorry what was your name tchau
tchau
short for Chelsea okay all right what's
on your mind today I have an observation
that I just kind of want your take on
okay um I I feel like I am like
progressive in general like I don't know
like I'm a very famous literary
supported image 2016 and I'm supporting
him now I but I just feel like I want
Marianne Williamson to come and give us
all some political therapy because I
don't know I like this valley of anger
and like really toxicity and I feel like
a lot of Gators are like kind of
avoiding discussing like what the root
cause of it is and I'm trying to decide
whether it's like the hatred that people
have for Howie cause it is so strong
like the love for Bernie Sanders that
are causing like so much chaos I don't
know I definitely notice anger in the
political world I think a lot of the
anger is warranted because we've had
ideologues and corporations and their
lobbyists basically take over and
control every aspect of life and you
know rape and pillage the lower and
middle classes for their benefits so
like I get the anger we look at other
countries that are as rich as ours and
we see that they have things that
for whatever reason we're told we can't
have at the expense of having this
completely overinflated military so I
get the anger I think that what you're
pointing out where I would agree is that
there is a degree of toxic infighting on
the left and I've talked about about it
myself where if you're not on a hundred
percent with the people who set the
litmus test you're sort of thrown out is
if you're not even a valid person on the
side that we're all on and I think that
that is the problem on the left that I
would most identify these kind of you
know if you're not with us on everything
yeah you're you might as well be against
us I mean you know the West versus right
saying is something they're someone's
gonna happen but I'm specifically
talking about fighting among progressive
yeah you know I see it in politics
politics the whole rationale issue which
I just I don't really get into because
like I'm tired of like talking about it
thinking about it yeah I know but there
was a lot of fighting around it you're
right yeah I don't like a lot of opinion
from them ii like people I really
respected who ignores one part of the
more important because they think that
it was somehow a malady you know Hillary
Clinton law I'm being mortified
big enhance in some way you know and
then they came on support their you know
they feel like Chancellor's exoneree and
not because being white trunks living
things like his presidency or what he's
doing but because they don't want to
like think about any other possible
reason for her loss other than herself
which I was marginally agree she lost
because of herself
I know candidate you know people who
have conservative lean hello you can
serve
yes okay Wow
all right ciao I think she said her name
was thank you for the call I agree with
you about some of the internal
infighting just being really really bad
all right that's all the time we have
today we will take calls again that's it
we'll go to a break sorry to everybody I
did not get to